what the
what here
um we were just talking about something
oh i'm hearing that echo we're
we're ringing throughout the place yeah
we were just
did mark just made a really good wap
joke you really had to be there like
five minutes before it happened because
the lead up was fantastic
when we dropped the single uh it'll all
make sense then you'll understand
um hey is it gonna be like that the
whole time do you hear the
do you hear that i guess we're hearing
it from that tv and that speaker
can you kill that i mean not that it's
that bad but it's
it's like we're listening to the show
look there's you can't see but maybe you
can see the bottom ahead scrambling
around the
[ __ ] bottom of the screen that's jc
and andrew trying to rectify it sounds
like it went away
yes there we go now we're here just
ourselves uh
okay hey hello hey
welcome to fat man beyond i'm kevin
smith i am mark bernard
hey let's start the show the way that it
started as an 80s cop show
hey oh there's this thing behind it
still got a spit guard ladies and
gentlemen so come down to the scum and
villainy
uh salad bar and you could sneeze guards
galore everybody
let us not spit on you we have so
much to discuss ladies and gentlemen oh
damn
today was is continues to be because
it's a 24-hour
worldwide event the dc
fandom named because
they took the fans and they [ __ ]
rocked their domes good lord
they pulled no punches no way better
than taking the fans and putting them
under the dome because as far as i know
where they'd be like
it doesn't yeah man and then you pull
back you find out the dome
is a snow dome that mr freeze is holding
and he's like revenge
is a dish best served
um dc took over the internet today
they did they did it changed the game
did you know you've heard of that was
the disney
thing is d2323 this was dc 23
essentially
nice thank you trademark kevin martin
um they uh this probably big game
changer as far as the san diego
comic-con goes too
everybody realizing we can have our
own branded events like you know disney
does it with d23
i'm sure after this dc fandom thing
i wouldn't be shocked to see like
[ __ ] the marvel universe
event weekend or whatever the [ __ ] i
mean star wars has celebration
where you know every couple of years
they go down and drop a bunch of news
and
yeah this whole feeling of curated
specialty branded
singular ip driven convention
is not new but in this world it feels
like maybe we're breaking some some new
ground
it feels like warren brothers dc is now
this is their they just created
something they're going to stick with
forever
they own the internet for the day they
did and it was
you know it's the second one of these
we've kind of seen because comic-con
itself put on
a sort of virtual convention um with
varying varying degrees of success well
this one was just so
like brand oriented that you know
it was like it was overwhelming in a
great way
whereas comic-con is dispersed between
many different subjects and whatnot
this was all about though you [ __ ]
like batman
you [ __ ] like zack snyder's batman
you're gonna get more [ __ ]
welcome to the fandom
like they really played it up to those
of us that liked
dc and they delivered they made me
they reminded me why i'm a fan yeah i
mean by the end of the
programming day i was like what like
especially with the big drops and stuff
yeah
i mean we'll get into a little bit more
a little bit later about why i thought
it was a success yeah as a format and as
an experience
and as a guy who was under the dome
himself
under the dome don't be shy tell him you
were under the dumpster i was under the
dome the secret dc panel that
dropped at 145 this was the relationship
mark was
in under the dome and i was like he's
why is he there
what's happening under the door mark it
was a milestone universe they announced
the milestone
sort of resurrection back to publishing
they announced that there's a static
shock movie that's in like early
development
makes sense um which was really exciting
was on the panel um it was me
um as the moderator uh dennis cowan
reggie hi
dennis cowan great dennis count um who's
a lovely lovely dude
uh reggie hudlin and jim lee
right on and phil lamar oh
the voice of static of virgil hawkins
and the animators and he came back
and he came back and uh that yeah static
is something that
like you could easily do today i mean
when the cartoon happened and when the
combo captain it was like you know
kid flying around blah blah blah now
yeah that's the easiest thing in the
world to do
yeah and that cartoon you know was also
on for four or five years yeah built in
200 some odd episodes i won
all kinds of awards shocking that
actually that that wasn't
the cw show that happened already
i mean like with all due respect to
black lightning like the hero of black
lightning
is like you're my dad whereas like
static shot
teenage dog yeah static shock that could
have been like ah he's a kid just like
all the cw kids
yeah i mean and i i i don't know what
went to behind the decision of that
um i mean i like black lightning a lot
and i get it like you're you're talking
yeah i'm not saying like [ __ ] that it's
just crazy that cw
hasn't even wrapped it up but i think
that in the in the wake of
um into the spider-verse it seems as if
which itself miles morales itself feels
like a spiritual descendant to
virgil hawkins and static but the fact
that
animation like warner animation group
hasn't said oh [ __ ] we have one of these
already and we've had it for 20 years
and
all we got to do is heat it up like
it was like 92-93 and and it was kind of
great because jim lee was talking about
going to to comic con and dennis cowan
was relaying the story of the milestone
debut
at comic-con and and how very much they
were inspired by image comics
and like all right we're gonna go down
there we're gonna make a big [ __ ] you
know
splashy debut we're gonna have a party
and we're all gonna wear suits and
jim was like i'm jealous why do they get
to wear suits and why are they gonna
have a party why can't we have parties
it was very adorable just talking about
you know that time in comics and how
impressionable everybody was and how
everything was possible you could just
decide you wanted to have a label
and a publishing company and you
assemble the talent and you make it
happen
and to be able to be the tiniest part
of at least announcing to the world that
coming very cool
go back in time and tell the young mark
bernard seriously it's like dude guess
what so wait when they say
the milestone icon icon rocket
um hardware like they're they're kind of
re-energizing and resurrecting the
entire line
adding some new titles and some new
characters um reggie hudlin is writing a
static book that dennis cowan is drawing
i think there's another
static ogm that's coming um yeah
they're back in a big way and i think dc
smartly is realizing that oh we were
just leaving money on the table
wise wise decision um hey there's
somebody that's not static
that sure looks like black adam doesn't
it
does is that who it is indeed does he
have a cape in the comics
um he has like the tiny little elvis
cape yeah
this one look at that yeah that's a
that's a cape for all seasons mark
it's an all-weather case that's a cloak
yeah really no doubt
hey before we dive in into the fandom
um shall we uh point out that we have
a sponsor this week ladies this episode
of fat man beyond is being brought to
you by the good folks
at doordash that's right doordash
the people that you app up when you
wanna
fill up get apps as in appetizers
we're working on the yeah we'll get the
jingle down yeah
we got to get some riders because we
don't know any but we'll get a rider
in here and we'll come because come to
some come up some sort of
doordash slogan that will tickle your
fancy
doordash they'll even deliver to the
batcave there you go there you go
they'll even deliver to your back door
on bro oh that's a sexy version
on brand uh for our show uh good folks
at doordash folks
uh when you're hungry and you're lazy
like me
you want somebody to bring you food
doordash
is who you go to man they got that
touchless delivery service now
contactless
you just they leave it right there and
let you know it's there and you go grab
it and you don't even have to like worry
about the germs and stuff like that i
used doordash a lot when i was doing my
burger brackets and my chicken sandwich
brackets there's a guy who was uh
competing with food having a food
competition during the beginning of this
quarantine
and i'm just not i'm not just a member
of the doordash community i'm the
president of it
and that's why this ad is free free for
you he's the president
but yeah i mean there were there were
weeks when you know we were doing fast
food burgers
and restaurant burgers and this was
early on in the in the pandemic and like
i wasn't hot to leave the house and i
wasn't hot to like be walking into
restaurants and stuff and so doordash
came in very very handy to like and
especially was like i got to get two
sets of deliveries from two opposing
parts of town like
bring them to my house i get to be the
nexus of all things delicious
also like one of the granddaddies of all
this will bring food to your door
business they've been around for a red
hot minute they've been around for red
hot minute and and
they've been you know doing very good
work at a time when people desperately
needed
to have you know a way to get food into
their houses
and not expose themselves in ways that
were untoward
you like food you like when it's brought
to you
the way mom used to remember how mom
used to like get on an app and order
food
when you were a kid well you could be
your own mother
now by going to doordash man and if
you're gonna go to doordash
uh right now our listeners can get five
bucks off man and zero delivery fees on
their first order
of fifteen dollars or more how do you do
that you ask when you download the
doordash
app you enter the code fat man
the very appropriate code for a very
appropriate app
they might want to rethink that code
maybe beyond yeah
yeah beyond a little less
pre-determinate
because if you if you order a lot of
doordash you will get fat man
like trust me that's what i've learned
during the quarantine
you'll never forget that code don't
forget that code ladies and gentlemen
that
code is fat man all one word for five
bucks off
your first order with doordash there's a
five dollars off
your and zero your order and zero
delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter the code
fat man thank you to doordash for
sponsoring
uh tonight's program and now i'm with
the countdown
casey's coast to coast hello
we've got a long distance dedication
from the fandom
um hey man yeah what a [ __ ] day
uh you know i was not prepared for how
hey how much i was willing to sit in
front of my computer on a day off
um and how much i was willing to like
run back and forth from doing other [ __ ]
to be like oh
i got my calendar set i'm sorry there's
a suicide squad reveal now
i'll talk to you later family yeah it
was it was the
gift that just keep kept on giving for
years people be
going like how come dc can't get their
[ __ ] together but
i dc has clearly gotten their [ __ ]
together
um they gave us a look
a couple looks at uh some forthcoming dc
cinematic universe fair that was
exciting and i think that the thing and
we had talked about it
still is exciting we talked about a
couple years ago is that
it seems as if with batman v superman
and even justice league
dc was trying to get into the same game
that marvel was in which was let's
let's introduce these characters let's
slap together a universe let's slap
together a universe
and it seems as if they've realized
wisely to their credit
that the thing they had that marvel
didn't have was a multiverse
and and and that's what can set them
apart and the long legacy of dc
in the movies is an asset not something
to steer away from
yes and so you get this feeling of oh
[ __ ] you can actually have a flash movie
with six batmans in it and it will all
make sense and it's not like we just
recast a dude it's like this is all part
of the story
these these varied and sundry and
wonderful different ways we've already
ingested this stuff
is part of the way we do it and they
realize now that the audience is smart
enough to be like ooh
that's the batman from years ago
and this is the batman from the other
day like now they could piece together
the multiverse without being like i
don't get it why is this guy here why is
that guy there why are there so many
batmans and stuff
um dc fandom uh kicked off today however
yesterday
was the news that bat fleck
yes returns ladies and gentlemen ben
affleck returning
for the flash movie playing the batman
that he played
in zack snyder's universe um
michael keaton who's also going to be
yeah he ain't going away there's going
to be two batman if not more
in this movie two of the most famous
batman in cinematic batman history
uh michael keaton and ben affleck it
sounds like now is this official or is
this rumored no it's official
[ __ ] official man that was nuts um
which made everyone real happy on the
internet yesterday because like what
more backflip
and there have been rumors for a while
like there might be an hbo max thing or
something
this is even better i'd assume and uh
was the director's name
andy uh machete i believe he said like
hey man
like you know you need bruce wayne you
need particularly this bruce wayne
batfleck bruce wayne because he knows
barry allen and you know he knows this
barry allen he's that barrier
and they both lost parents they both
lost to mom
and you know there's something about
that ties them together and stuff
uh his mom barry's mom was not named
martha so
no worries there um but you know they
really
read con all together so uh they
revealed that
like the the it's getting [ __ ] even
better
yeah than we thought it was going to be
that flash movie
pretty incredible so that was before the
fan dome began
yeah that was a that was a precursor to
the unveiling of the fandom no doubt
so what happened when they opened the
fandom i mean the first thing we got
when they opened the fandom was wonder
woman 84.
that's how they opened could you imagine
that's how they opened a lot of people
would close with like [ __ ]
here's a c here's the latest trailer
here's cheetah
for the first time ever like never mind
just kristen wiig walking around in
clothes
here is [ __ ] cheetah we're not
[ __ ] around yeah with her tail
full out you know never mind seeing the
lego version
here you go we're not hiding anything
anymore they could have built to that
that's how they opened
no they they had a lot to do and so much
to reveal
that wonder woman could be your opener
and it still didn't feel top heavy um
my i loved seeing cheetah well should we
just roll the trailer and then we'll
talk about it we have that
we have that we have the technology
ladies and gentlemen let's
look at the trailer for wonder woman
together
shall we
that looks expensive look at all that
money is it the same little girl you
think who played one that couldn't be
right
wait wonder woman in the first time i
don't think so right because
the kids grow don't they there she is
riding the lightning metallica style man
in a minute
a minute look at that logo what does it
scream 80s
staticky 80s look at that giant now that
must be the thing that projects
uh what's your name maxwell lourdes he
gets a
magic wishing rock of some sort and
that's how that's how we get
the return of uh steve trevor right here
from most people are saying online
that's speculation mind you they don't
tell you in the trailer but you know
it's from this wishing stone
thing which sounds hokier than a you
know
i kind of mean it anyone i want to be my
nepex predator
i like it because now we're getting a
little bit of a hint into what cheetah
you've always been and what her
worldview and why she has had nothing
i love kristen i think she's a wonderful
actress she was great on marshall my
turn
like she's funny as [ __ ] right and like
bridesmaids but i think she's really
great actors i think this is dope
so we get to see some fighting of her in
a cheetah inspired outfit
um but you know of course we all
wondered would she go full cheetah
uh and boy oh boy does she
fight scenes galore man writing not even
like i thought this was adorable
they will never find us honestly i love
cheetah but i think he's my favorite
thing in the trailer
i'll watch so many movies about chris
pine as steve trevor
look at that [ __ ] man bang tale
cheetah oh
eagle armor that's dope man that's like
right out of a comic book
wonder woman vs cheetah never thought
i'd see a live action version of this
in my lifetime we are blessed
on this one i blessed uh you are my
favorite part of the trailer coming
right up ready to go
not the fanny pack that was cute but
this next pick
this yeah does everybody parachute now
his delivery of does everybody parachute
now like was
so pitch perfect uh he's adorable he's
he's he seems to be like the secret
weapon of every movie that he's in yeah
make him
i mean he was great [ __ ] captain kirk
make him a
what can we cast him as what superhero
they encounter reed richards
you'd be a charm or johnny you know
storm but he's a little on the older
side
yeah i mean make him dr doom man real
charming like that
but also and is it like doctor doom
pretty as [ __ ] under the mask
uh yeah there's one incarnation where
they do the story where he's wearing
this mask and he takes it off and
he has one minor [ __ ] flesh wound and
he's so
vain that he buried himself but i don't
want to bury that face under a mask
god he's charming that looks fantastic
patty jenkins made a hell of a [ __ ]
movie from the looks of it
yeah um and you can tell they want to
release the [ __ ] out of this they're
looking look here's something
here's everything please please just
come come come come come come to the
video they got my money i mean i'm not
this is the same studio so i'm not
raising one to lower another but like
that would get me out to the theaters
before tenet would
you know i know a lot of people like
[ __ ] you chris and i love chris nolan
don't get me wrong but
that makes me excited yeah
did you watch the panel i wasn't that
excited no
there was a panel they had a whole
[ __ ] half hour panel before they
revealed the footage really
yeah you know me man i skipped the
kissing and the
and the foreplay i went right in for the
the cutest part of the panel
was that linda carter showed up no yes
and so watching like kristen wiig
lose her [ __ ] and geek out over linda
carter was the most adorable thing
that's really dope man wow i wonder if
linda carter
i mean not for nothing but you could do
that if you wanted to there if we're
living in a multiverse
there's a 1980s version of wonder woman
that already exists
whoa whoa that could be in the flash
it could be in the flash ladies
all right so fandom kicks off with
wonder woman
looking fantastic this movie looks great
ready to see it
just when you were like [ __ ] it could
get better than this what was next
uh on the dc eu front on the film front
yeah suicide squad
[ __ ] it was man look this is before
the trailer dropped there was a this is
unconfirmed
but one of the websites i think it was
illuminati or something
okay reported that the villain
of the movie have you seen this uh i i
don't think
speculation so it's rumors galore rumors
galore but the
the villain they're saying of suicide
squad
uh spoilers if you don't want to know
this all over twitter
okay so i am breaking news here uh
starro and that is [ __ ] brilliant
come on man we're living in a world
where star was gonna be the bad guy
you're gonna see [ __ ] with [ __ ]
this on their faces star fishes
starfish is on their faces man that's so
[ __ ] trippy they've described the
movie as a war film
a 1970s war film well let's let's play
the
because there were two pieces of footage
we saw today yeah so the character
reveals
of who the [ __ ] is in the suicides which
would have been enough which would have
been enough
and then we got a little behind the
scenes thing so let's play the character
reveals
and then we'll we'll just swim in all
the jokes they should do this for every
[ __ ] movie what's that
yeah yeah they should do this for every
movie man like show the [ __ ] who's in
the cast with a little cartoon complete
the mission you get 10 years off your
sentence
is bad which i wasn't sure she was then
happy
uh rick flag
michael rooker man well it would not be
a james gunn movie
and he's playing this what savannah
savant yeah this is javelin
oh newcomer margot yeah i wonder what
you'll do with the role in the
uh there's our boy dave the small chad
playing the polka dot man rat catcher
catcher two it's daniella milton that's
right the first one was a dude right
[Music]
mongal was in it nor did i know that
peter capaldi was playing the thinker
it's perfect
beat david fishes
black guard nathan fillion is tdk
now what is tdk i don't know eric
carrasco our friend and you know uh
motu fellow writer he thinks it's arms
fall off boy
i thought this was genius john how do
you pronounce center
cena uh but peacemaker man i can't
believe we're getting a live-action
live-action peacemaker he comes from
charlton comics man
i love what in the in the
behind-the-scenes thing that we're gonna
watch he describes him as a doucher
captain america
yeah okay peace at all costs even
[ __ ]
killing people um all right so that
would have been enough and for a while
but then they gave us actual [ __ ]
footage they gave us crazy footage with
a trailer where
you know essentially everyone was like
james [ __ ] gun
he was a big part of the marketing for
that i mean he moderated the panel
and like did a pretty good job of it um
and i really liked
it i wonder i wonder how we managed to
do that yeah work with all those suicide
squads how did he keep them all in line
yeah well he now controls how much
footage they have in the movie truly um
but i i really appreciated the way these
panels seem to incorporate both
just enough interaction with the cast of
the movie but also a lot of fan
interaction a lot of fan questions a lot
of fan video questions
i think that's part of what was missing
with the the comic-con version of this
the official san diego version just felt
like you were watching
something as opposed to participating in
it true and even though this was this
was also pre-recorded and very much of
it
and you know you couldn't live ask
questions to a cast
somebody got to you know and that sense
of there is
it's about the fans and so incorporating
the fans in a big way
helped make this feel a little bit more
organic as what feels like
a panel at a comic con where there's a
bunch of people online to ask questions
and
only three of them will get through and
those three good bad and different
it's yeah there's a texture to that that
i really like
uh that uh the cast
you know sound off was great this
trailer
yeah i mean look i was already on board
i [ __ ] love what james gunn's doing
um i love that cast i love the suicide
squad
um i i think the idea of james gunn
doing the suicide squad is like
brilliant um
so i was already on board but i thought
this [ __ ] trailer was phenomenal yeah
and it looks like they're making a
[ __ ] rip [ __ ] fun movie and if
they're right about staro being the bad
guy
holy [ __ ] and it's also it's so fun and
it's not even really a trailer
it's like behind the scenes epk [ __ ]
really was
and it just still it has so much energy
to it and so much enthusiasm
it's uh it's kind of a quick shot of
king shark too doing his thing
like let's i can't wait to see an actual
trailer that's telling me some of the
story but
take a peek and gush the suicide squad
part two
no just the suicide squad they just
added a though i think it's gonna
surprise people
you kind of sit there and go how did
they do that
it's gonna be different from any
superhero movie ever made
see jane's gun sitting there he's
to be able to do the suicide squad in
the way it could be done from my point
of view
this one is completely unique this is a
gritty 1970s war movie
combined with brilliance of james gunn's
characters and comedy
you need your director to set the vibe
the suicide squad
i love i love the
within each of our characters harley
quinn with the most clothes on
thus far than most of them some of them
are just pretty crappy through and
through
that then that big thing behind him
looked like an eye of
the sorrow
okay i got it don't ever settle back
like you think you know where this is
going because
you don't as soon as you have some sense
about what's about to happen next
james comes in
everyone's exploding genitals heads arms
legs
genitals massive graphic novel brought
to life
this is by far the biggest movie i've
ever made
do you see king james don't know what to
expect don't get too attached
this has been truly the greatest
most exciting journey of my life making
this film
cut that was great
i'm in god damn it that looks [ __ ]
good
he's talented it i i 100
want this version of the suicide squad
yeah like it it
and the other one made as much money as
it did that one
yeah gonna be [ __ ] well i mean if if
people are allowed to go to movie
theaters and
we get a vaccine indeed that movie's
going to make [ __ ] more than
the original god it looks like so much
fun i mean
and the fact that you have [ __ ] 28
heroes quote unquote heroes in it
gives you room for people to die yes you
know we're gonna lose some [ __ ]
we're gonna it's the suicide squad not
everybody should make it
they shouldn't and sean gunn playing
weasel and strong and bling weasel
and jai courtney back as captain
boomerang one of the yeah
an unlikely survivor indeed something
tells me he might not make it all the
way through
think so that's just me though he's in
the suicide squad game though
that's that are we talking about that
game or no um i'm not
sidebar there's that game there is there
it is
um the trailer for it was amazing where
the open
of the game or whatever there were a
couple of dope game drops though the
gotham their villain did you see that
their villain is in the game no brainiac
that's cool
yeah so he takes over looks like
superman and then they gotta fight
they gotta kill superman well the gotham
knights trailer which that also looked
dope
it starts with a dead bruce wayne starts
with a debruce wayne just sort of
sending out the call to fill the void
and there's a playable batgirl which
we've never had before right and the bad
guys the villain quarter of owls
who is it quarterbacks yes the
quarterbacks at the end they did the
whole quarterbacks thing
which is so bad girl looked a little bit
like the dc
super hero girls version of batgirl yeah
like yeah like there's
a lot of the images of her it looked
like to me
not full cowl mask and like ears
sticking out of her hair
then i saw a shot in the trailer of full
cowl as well but
yeah i i was i was trying to figure out
where they pulled their look from and it
kind of looked like that i could be
wrong but that game looks dope too i'm
not a
gamer but [ __ ] did that [ __ ] look cool
yeah i have no idea what the gameplay is
like
but i would watch that [ __ ] trailer
over and over and over i'd watch a
trailer over and over again once they
started the gameplay that's when i was
like nope that would take me two years
to learn
how to do any of those things at one
time too many buttons
having a hard time beating my own game
jay and sound bob mall brawl
so i don't know that i can handle that
game um all right so anything else on
suicide squad any reveals
no not for me man i'm just that was
enough and i'm super jazzed by it it's
fantastic and god bless james gunn he's
doing the lord's work making a movie
like that look [ __ ] that fantastic
um hey amen kids
i've never been more in support of
suicide
i don't i don't know what else to put it
sounds weird
um before we dive into the next story
monday night
yeah at the drive-in in vineland
the vineland drive-in in city of
industry yes
what is it paramount driving or no no
paramount was the one that we went to
for my birthday this one is called the
vineland drive-in
and it's in city of industry um they are
we we're doing a hollywood babylon 10th
anniversary
show me and ralph doing babylon talking
about the stars
under the stars very nice uh tickets at
csbod.com
anyway back to the news back to the news
the next panel
we got um from the dc eu was black adam
okay this i mean look i'm all happy for
i'm glad this movie exists but this is
the one that
felt like you know like my dog ate my
homework
like didn't they unless i'm wrong didn't
they cut together like an animated
trailer they haven't shot anything yet
right yeah so it's just like hey we we
got half an hour with it's a cool
picture and i ain't [ __ ] on it
i liked what i saw but at the end of the
day they were like
we better do something because we got to
do something and
you know so jim lee apparently you know
consulted and worked with the boss logic
dude who does all those awesome posters
oh get out of here they were the guys
who sort of pre-vised and created that
opening cinematic
that's cool and you know like again you
get the rock for half an hour then
you're going to talk about the rock
smoothie for half an hour
and you know it sounds kind of
interesting i mean i don't know that
much about black adam
outside of his interracial interactions
with
with shazam but this seems like it's a
standalone movie
potentially with it seems as if he was
maybe even hinting at superman being the
antagonist
yes he uh he said well he seemed
it seemed animated that shazam wasn't
gonna be the [ __ ] antagonist but yes
that the man of steel himself
indeed would come back and uh in a world
where everyone wants
henry cavill to come back and he seems
to like to want to come back and
everyone loves dwayne the rock dwayne
the rock johnson
if anyone can make it happen that dude
can make a call
um and the fact that like the jsa are
also a big part of this and so you're
going to get
carter hall as harkman you're going to
get dr fate you're getting cyclone
you're getting
we're going to get dr [ __ ] fate dr
[ __ ] fate
and the helmet of naboo in our lifetime
[ __ ] amazing so yeah i'm looking forward
to all that but
their their offering was it's
let's look at the rock yeah it was good
in like the tightest sweater you can
find like between him and john cena
who seems to be like can we get this
polo like nine sizes too small
like baby size if i look like that i'd
be shirtless
never mind [ __ ] tight clothes that's
fair um
all right so black adam looking great
looking great but
super early but way early we ain't seen
that movie for like [ __ ] two years
easy i mean i haven't started production
yet and who the hell knows when that's
gonna happen so
they did mention there was a shazam 2
panel right there was which i didn't
watch
no footage or anything but uh the
sinbad showed up like the actors in bed
yes
and because a lot of people were like
there was a discussion about the mandela
effect because everyone thinks that
sinbad was in a movie called shazam but
he wasn't
right he was in another movie called
because was it cousin no uh shaquille
o'neal
is in kazan so then who is sinbad hasn't
been in anything
i don't believe there's a so that's why
there's a mandela effect
conversation where they're like no you
were in kazam he's like i was not i
swear to god
that's hysterical um although i also
have this weird memory of like at the
very least shazam
in in some kind of like genie hat
like nodding and [ __ ] happening but that
could also be the mandela effect
this is going to work on me so he was on
that panel
for reasons well they're saying he might
be in the movie
uh you know what if he's in the movie as
like the the high school football coach
of that kid or as somebody i saw
somebody on twitter suggest
what if he was the voice of talky tiger
cool you know i'll take it right
somebody said the sinbad assange has
begun
i love that like one dude gets a job and
there's an assault involved
he's the next mcconaughey man one guy
gets a job
no it's just i'm working man that's good
news though man i'm i'm happy for simba
i'm happy for somebody catching a
[ __ ] uh shazam two
cameo gives me hope when they get to
shazam nine maybe they're like hey
silent bob you wanna [ __ ] pop in here
um that was shazam two which they've
given a title to fury of the gods
wow that's intense i apparently paid
more attention than you did i didn't
watch that panel
you had your head up your ass all the
other parents because here's the thing
like i i was really sure like here's the
thing [ __ ] shazam
but no he's like the more i started to
watch it yeah
the more it felt as if i was just
spending another day at work
like i'm huddled all over my computer
looking at faces and boxes i'm like oh
i'm just zooming again
yeah and so i need a break from this to
let it feel a little bit like a saturday
and like wash my ass and take a shower
and i chose shazam
that was the moment that was washing was
going on that was the moment
um all right so what happened next that
first shazam movie was fun though
adorable
um neck after that justice league zack
snyder's justice league
which was probably one of the biggest
things that everyone was looking forward
to today
shy of of course matt reeves batman um
the batman
they dropped uh the
trailer for with the official title is
zack snyder's justice league
correct um and uh it broke the internet
everyone very excited um we got it
we got it let's see it it opens with
[ __ ] boy they didn't even bury the
lead
no they literally opened this trailer
with like the shot that you would
imagine they would close the trailer
with i thought that was rather ballsy
um and that shot of course is dark side
i thought it'd be up by now but we're
still stalling i guess for
okay there it is
look at there he is dark side right up
front
i mean i know he put the picture out
online a little while ago but like
it's crazy uh this song mark leonard
cohen
cover of hallelujah yes familiar
it you know if i didn't know better i
would say that the only cd that zack
snyder owns
is the soundtrack to his watchman this
song of course
uh was in the watchman movie the during
the sequence where
um night owl had sex
yes and um
you know that was the part of the movie
a lot of people
went after would make fun of a lot of
memes about it and stuff like that
so the fact that zack snyder was just
like
it's it's the like quentin you show
feet too much in your movies and you get
to once upon a time in hollywood and
it's just
feet on the glass just like [ __ ] you
double down um the trailer uh is
exciting of course but it's uh
basically um a lot of footage that we
saw
hints of in other trailers but then
things we've never seen before
um and interactions that's the sod i
believe right there
um it hints out a movie that we didn't
quite see
yes look at this sequence totally you
know
watch what happens to vic stone's dad
don't kill joe morton he goes full uh
you know
look at look at uh steppenwolf he looks
like the original rendering at the end
of
batman v superman and there's batman
defending himself against a pair of
demon there's flash
looking at space time you know the one
thing they talked about in that flash
panel i guess jim lee
confirmed was that um the
uh ezra
was his name miller ezra miller flash
is getting his name the flash from that
scene
in the in the crossover and the crisis
on empanadas probably fought
hundreds of thousands of other super
beings on the other planets he's
destroyed right and we have to assume
he's one
i don't care how many demons he's fought
and how many hells
he's never fought us not us united
what he said i don't care how many
demons he's fought and how many hells
yeah he's never fought us not
united not united it's good line um yeah
i mean it's it's
it's looking at the stuff that he had
always told us we were going to see yes
the information
are you kidding me are we still live on
facebook
that's that's hysterical that is we were
having a conversation about this before
have they come for us apparently they
are
why why would they be like
don't talk about it yeah don't show that
yeah don't talk about our trailer which
we put on the internet
for such purposes who's got a facebook
lead do we know if we're still up on
facebook
should we should we continue speaking
uh oh my god kids you're seeing
backstage apparently
somebody over at warner brothers or one
of their bots through a
snit what happened
facebook's still up but youtube went
down youtube went down if you're
watching on facebook kids and you see
everyone running around
going wha it's because they just chucked
us off youtube because we showed the
zack snyder trailer
yeah for zack snyder's justice like man
oh man
that's power it and it's it's apparently
too hot to handle that they don't want
us to handle
it's crazy we weren't even saying bad
things about it not a single thing
and i wasn't even like they didn't know
i was gearing up for it
hi youtube folks welcome back folks at
youtube
if you're wondering what happened that
wasn't us we got booted
uh cut to jc breaking news
what the [ __ ] happened i don't know i
watched the stream and monitor the chat
and then the screen turned black and it
said
violation and it was just a black screen
and i panicked
uh fair so is it was it what you think
it was
i think it's uh the leonard cohen song
it's a music violation i think it was
the leonard cohen killed us
not the not necessarily warner
interesting very interesting i mean that
and we had this conversation before we
even got on the air
about sort of showing trailers again
which are designed to be advertising
material they're promotional at heart
and as digital journalists we have it
within our rights to be able to
contextualize said trailers
and when he says digital journalists he
means journalists with fingers
indeed
how strange we were having this
conversation and mark was being all
sorts of like
[ __ ] that yeah they [ __ ] how come
entertainment tonight could show trailer
[ __ ] that we're putting up a trailer
yeah they're saying that youtube shut
everybody who tried to do anything with
that trailer that the leonard
cohen music shut it down to everybody
too wow look at that man
all right well great leonard cohen i
knew i didn't like that
from beyond the grave just shut it all
down
um all right well [ __ ] at any rate
apparently big brother is watching
indeed [ __ ]
uh at any rate like it's we we had heard
that a lot of this footage was coming
you know zach has talked about it zach
has given
glimpses of it and teases of it over the
course of the last year or so
and so the seat all stitched together
it's kind of cool um
and to get the news the the big news
that dropped out of it was not just the
leak
the leak here comes the big news the
reveal of the of the teaser itself
but it's going to be a four hour mini
series
um so we will get an hour a night for
four consecutive nights or potentially
four consecutive weeks depending on how
they choose to
dole it out on the most expensive
television mini series in history
um probably that'll be right
i don't know how much um watchmen cost
but i
wouldn't doubt that was cheap either oh
i can't imagine it costs as much as
justice league well you got to put in
all the costs mark not just zack
snyder's justice league
but the you know joss whedon justice
league
as well as the hbo what was their new
logo it's like warner max or something
like that yeah warner max
as well as that so amortized put all
those costs together
maybe the most expensive mini series
ever made it could be
i mean i'm here for it though i'll take
an hour i'm glad that they're breaking
it into an hour or four nights as
opposed to or an hour
four viewings as opposed to two two
hours or one giant movie
yeah and it was interesting to see in
the in the zack snyder panel
um ray fisher was there no he was
because the person that ray fisher is
mad at is not zack snyder no
god he wore that i heart zs shirt on
stage the comic con
indeed um and there's we'll have some
more uh ray fisher stories
later on there's there's more in the
news about [ __ ] happened outside of
fandom i thought all we were doing was
fandom apparently there'll be more news
there'll be no q a tonight ladies and
gentlemen because there's nothing but
news
or they could shut us down again for
talking about the wrong thing that's
true
that was exciting a song um we were
censored ladies and gentlemen
we were the man came down and said
really hard
in any event any event so that was so
that looks great can't wait to see it
i'm so happy for him he gets to make his
movie i think it's very funny that he
he used hallelujah um i saw
many satisfied release the snyder
cutters
folks that were just like yes like
that's the perfect song
so good i can't wait man 2021
um it seems to be it's already looking
better up there in the future
can't wait to get there i mean
everything looks better in the future
because the right now
not so great although today was a pretty
good day because we were all
under the fandom and there were so many
masks yes
we were all oh come on that was good
um all right what else we got hey in
that's in that uh trailer
which might have gotten cut off and [ __ ]
we got you know when they booted us off
they had uh the black superman suit
they did him like opening doors and
walking out in the suit
that was pretty pretty damn cool that's
pretty badass i like a good black suit
oh yeah um all right i mean that was
everyone wanted to see it remember
yeah so bad um i'm still you know
holding out hope for the mustache cut
at some point because i just i want to
see that footage you got to wait another
like five years
yeah if this goes well you'll be seeing
the cut of everything
um the last big movie panel of the day
needless to say
der batman uh this show flighter mouse
named for a character called batman
um and boy oh boy
this trailer reminded you why you like
batman yeah and how malleable these
characters can be
um for the first time ever what did you
watch the panel did you watch any panels
no
um matt reeves i have a hard time
watching like
[ __ ] people talk when i'm not talking
you
i i like but some famous [ __ ] talking
about [ __ ] i'm like you know what let me
just watch the trailer
matt reeves like it was basically aisha
tyler interviewing matt reeves and they
had a little
snippet of a kind of video introduction
from rob pattinson
but he was really magnetic to watch like
his take on the entire batman universe
reeves yeah like he's given like real
deep serious thought to it
and talking about you know his
influences for what he was making the
movie and darwin cook's ego
was a big thing that he drew from is
that right chinatown was a really big
influence for him
um but just that sense that that the
multiverse lets you tell stories of lots
of different kinds of batman
and how his can be different it's it's
very
much in his words batman year two yes
he's been doing it for a while but not
having not finding the success that he
wanted
kind of looks more like what was uh
jeff john's book batman earth one like
looks like that like pragmatic practical
batman
right um but this looked like
[ __ ] the trailer for zodiac or seven
it's like batman seven
it's very it's very finchery yeah in
feel and tone
and it's only drawn from 25 of the movie
they only shot 25
in the movie so what we see in this
trailer isn't
does not in any way represent the
totality of it and we see a new
rendition
of uh the riddler indeed which is pretty
crimson and
spooky reminds me a little bit of uh
cronenberg's villain from nightbreed
the mask that he's wearing yeah um then
uh did you or did you not see
colin farrell in the trailer i didn't
notice it but i only watched it once and
so maybe on the second view
he's the heavyset gentleman in the
trailer who's like this guy's crazy
really i was blown away there's someone
in the trailer i can't identify i don't
know who it is like in the big
shot outside of like the police center
there's a guy with a beard looks like
russell crowe
current russell crowe not not gladiator
russell crowe steve bannon russell crowe
very much that's who's so when we watch
the trailer see if you know who that is
that one i couldn't identify but
because at the end of the trailer i was
like where's colin farrell and i think i
think it's colin farrell with a lot of
like
makeup on or prosthetics or something
let's take a peek
uh matt reeves directed a motion picture
in the midst of directing a motion
picture called
the batman from the director of the
pallbearer
it's crazy like god bless him man from
the guy who
gave you schwimmer and the pallbearer
pattinson
in the batman check it out ooh that's
crimson start with that [ __ ] tape
reminded me a red state when we wrap the
dude up with saran wrap and [ __ ]
that's that's a beginning of a [ __ ]
batman trailer dude
like somebody who's taping up a victim
look at that
that's some dark dark [ __ ] right there
um i gotta be honest with you a good
friend
this seeing uh jeffrey wright
as commissioner gordon you go like how
come that never
happened before like what a great piece
of casting that is
this i liked very much um
you know maybe we got to kill the music
on this too what if what if nirvana
just kill the volume i mean everyone's
we could watch this
everyone's seen it already um we don't
want to get booted off
youtube again [ __ ] they scared us um
what i like that guy right there who's
that guy in the beard oh i couldn't tell
so what i like about this is
batman walking around in the room with
all the cops there
you never [ __ ] see that no and it's
interesting because reeves was talking
about
how you know batman to the public
is a public enemy in this movie and so
he's still
kind of friendly with the cops or
they're rarely friendly enough to be on
a crime scene
with them still there he's not persona
non grata to the gotham pd
not yet anyway is that right so they
like him
at the rallies they tolerate them
apparently because he's there in the
room with the cops and stuff
um everyone keeps uh
i love this scene this is [ __ ] improv
look at look at him beat the [ __ ] out of
this guy
i mean like it speaks to the fact that
he's an angry [ __ ] dude
like it's not clinical here it's i'm
going to beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
until he doesn't get up
i am vengeance he says just like [ __ ]
kevin conroy i am vengeance i am the
knight
you still got the crab look right there
the guy who was just like this guy's
crazy
i think that might be colin farrell the
pac-man
there's the new logo uh they used a
nirvana track
who's this who's he talking to at the
end um
is it i don't know i think it's the
riddler who's talking i don't think
or is he talking i don't [ __ ] know
couldn't tell at the end man
um i like that that's pretty great
huh pretty great [ __ ] breakdown of
the date
uh man oh man what a way to end their dc
fan day under the fan dome that is a
tremendous [ __ ] trailer
uh i i want to see that batman movie now
that's going to be tied into the gotham
central tv show
and the interesting thing is that gotham
pd is taking place during batman year
one
ah so before all this right so it's the
beginning it's the there's
word of a [ __ ] mass vigilante and how
the police respond to it
and then the movie gets to be year two
that's really [ __ ] smart and dancing
i'm so happy about that trailer this is
a good [ __ ] trailer man and it's just
like tonally
using that nirvana track and [ __ ] like
how could nobody ever use the nirvana
track to sell a batman movie before
think about it they're not using a score
it's not like banana or [ __ ] you know
some
giant uh [ __ ] or whatever
you're literally playing a [ __ ]
nirvana track it really sets the tone
well and it's not like some
like 90s uh pop song slowed down
did you see that that trailer thing over
the week how to make a blockbuster
trailer
and it literally diagrams every moment
you've ever seen in a blockbuster
trailer
and it's like ominous voiceover offers a
question
and then like slow monotonous version of
a popular 90s song
and then strings come in and then
protagonist asks a question
introduce the antagonist answer in the
question and then dramatic reveal
all the fx footage like it's literally
every marvel trail you've ever seen
you're giving away the tricks of the
trade man i'm not the one like some dude
put it together and it's
perfect broke it down broke it down
that's marketing 101
indeed um this trailer man is impressive
i you know i was always always going to
be curious about what they did with the
the batman of course um and i was on
board regardless but
[ __ ] man i'm this is like the batman
movie we dreamed about as kids like
could you imagine if somebody treated it
super [ __ ] serious like this looks
like eric carrasco pointed out he goes
this looks like greg rucka batman yeah
like the one that feels rooted hardcore
in reality but still had room for
the fantasy elements of crime and gotham
these are versions of the characters
they said today
that are on their way to becoming the
iconic characters you know so you're not
going to see the penguin
as the penguin you're seeing the penguin
on his way to the penguin and this
incarnation of the riddler is not the
final incarnation
so it also gives an indication that
these villains won't be
willy-nilly killed at the end of things
you know unless there's the i mean the
the gotham tv show
not that we watched all of it but was
playing with the joker in the idea that
this person you're seeing who's laughing
like a loon
is not the joker we're going to
eventually meet and so there's a world
in which this riddler is not the
penultimate riddler that this is the
person who inspires the riddler
who then one-ups him or penguin or so
forth and so on
a lot of love for paul dano on the
internet
which was you know i mean look i'm all
for it i thought it was a great trailer
but everyone's like daniel better get
ready for his oscar now i'm like you
literally haven't seen his face in the
trailer
you saw a dude wrapped up in plastic and
you're ready to give the man an award
um i think it's a great use of the
character
making him like kind of like the zodiac
killer and [ __ ] like that
i saw someone online going like where's
his iconic suit i'm like
[ __ ] keep the suit man you wrap that
dude's head up in plastic with
like goggles on it that's [ __ ] way
more terrifying than the question mark
suit which by the way
is not terrifying at all and we've seen
many incarnations of it
i was happy to see this new version yeah
happy to be disappointed i wasn't
disappointed but
happy to be uh like oh [ __ ] that's not
what i thought they'd
where's his bowler hat where's his cane
i like this guy a lot more man he's just
got
[ __ ] tape yeah that's his [ __ ]
that's his that's his weapon
and i think we had talked you know a
while ago about the idea that
doing a batman movie that's about batman
the detective
you know and it seems very much like
he's trying to solve a string of murders
yeah and it's not so much as like we're
poisoning the reservoir
it's literally people are dying in
gotham although i'd like to see that
movie
i mean that could be the finale um the
uh but one thing is for sure he may be a
detective but when he
gets the to the like the dead end in the
case he just beats the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of people
that is like for you know we've seen
batman fight
many times in movies and one of the most
recent occasions of course
was in bvs that amazing scene where
[ __ ] batman takes out a room of
people and [ __ ]
this was pretty impressive for like a
straight on i'm just gonna hold on this
shot
and not cut around six different ways
and just let him
[ __ ] fast beat the [ __ ] out of this
guy
take him to the ground and then just
pound on him like a [ __ ]
child it's pretty pretty sweet it's very
clint eastwood
yeah it's very like here's just a dude
i'm gonna beat the [ __ ] out of this guy
and get up and ask his friends who wants
some yeah you better
bury ned right i'll come back and kill
all you sons of [ __ ] and hell's
coming with me
and morgan freeman's there he's like
wrong batman movie and then he leaves
um all right so [ __ ] that you know how
long we gotta wait for this is out next
week right mark
pretty much woohoo we're gonna be on
dvod pretty soon they could
believe me i'll pay a thousand dollars
to watch that movie right now
and i bet you a lot of people would do
as well more people than you would
imagine
i bet you yeah i mean they are still
promising 2021
as the last little bit of that teaser
showed
but they got 75 of a movie to shoot and
next year is 2021.
so and they're shooting in london and so
overseas has a much
they're they seem to be doing better
with the covet than we are
um so there's a world in which they can
be up and running in production again in
the next month or so
very rainy it is but might not be the
worst thing for a batman movie
no i'm saying the whole [ __ ] trailer
is very rainy they're shooting in
england it makes a lot of sense
right but yeah like last few batman
movies been shot stateside detroit
uh pittsburgh chicago l.a for a bit so
this returns
batman to england but shooting outdoors
in england which they didn't do in the
original movies they went to england
but then built gotham on a sound stage
and shot there shepparton studios
they're actually using
london they're usually in liverpool i
think liverpool is is at least according
to matt reeves a lot of the
sort of the wharfs and the the the parts
uh i have no idea liverpool so while
he's crawling up the side of a building
paul mccartney pops out the window hello
hello what you doing here love he's just
walking across penny lane
uh man oh man i want this movie so bad
i'm excited
i want it give me it um it'll be how do
you feel about the suit in the car
um the car i thought was badass you know
the car it's
again i really don't give a [ __ ] you
know like look no no [ __ ] batmobile
will ever be as wicked as
anton first's tim burton michael
keaton's batmobile which
we will see again in action
in the flash movie it feels like do you
see that art they put together
there's a shot of flash in a new outfit
and
michael keaton batman behind him you're
gonna see the car again
you better see the [ __ ] car oh we
love that batmobile but in any event uh
you know
i don't care like give him a car it's
fine i mean it looks like the muscle car
a dude would build in his garage if you
knew a bit about cars but don't have a
factory to build you
an anton first mobile or a tumbler or
anything right
right with a jet engine you still
apparently have access to a jet engine
you know
turns out you can get your hands on some
atomic batteries if you try hard enough
uh
sounded like we heard a piece of the
andy circus uh
alfred as well yeah a little bit of that
and a new batcave that kind of looked
see when a motorcycle pulled into
something it looked like it was a house
yeah or an underground library or some
such [ __ ]
did you see in the trailer for uh zack
snyder's justice league remember the one
that
youtube just threw us off for showing
did you see the shot
of the [ __ ] you know the wasteland
and it said
justice league of america like the arts
early on like
in there that was pretty dope um and we
got a little look at uh selena kyle
doing some catwoman we did
zoe kravitz recently of uh
of uh what's the show they just canceled
on hulu high fidelity high fidelity
um she don't need that show it's gonna
be huge it's gonna be cowboy there's a
once again a little uh shop
from behind where her outfit
created early affairs earbuds
uh earbuds um yeah i'm in man i
have this i've watched the trailer nine
times at home over and over on a giant
screen 103 inch television
on youtube man analyzing it and [ __ ] i
look forward to those videos with like
here's
a 30 easter eggs you missed i love that
um but man exciting how how [ __ ]
we're going to get another batman movie
we get another pretty damn soon
we're getting a lot of super cool [ __ ]
down the pike
from the dc eu and like i i have been
critical of it in the past
and i think that they seem to have found
their footing because all of this [ __ ]
looks pretty strong
yeah you know and and they seem to have
found their way to deliver a thing that
that will make
more than just die-hard fans just weep
over this [ __ ] that will actually
be able to transcend into full-on
mainstream entertainment
and i'm here for it may i suggest that
next year i'm sure they'll stick with
fandom from now until the end of time
but
the super friends also would have been a
good oh title because
that's we got you know a trailer for
wonder woman
a trailer for batman some suicide squad
they're not really in the
super friends but whatever all right it
all fell apart but i mean they could
have called it the super friends
they could have but the thing that
fandom lets you do dome
sounds metal it sounds metal and next
year when potentially we can all be in
the same place again
you could literally have a fan you don't
literally have a [ __ ] fandom
and you don't have to change the name at
all oh you better believe that's going
to happen man and warner brothers not
only
there because you can first write it off
as marketing costs
but you can collect money as well
selling tickets or something like that
who wouldn't [ __ ] pay look how many
people pay to go to d23
and what is that if not a marketing
event to get you excited for
more [ __ ] they're gonna sell you in a
couple weeks so i mean the thing that dc
never did on the convention floor would
sell anything
if you went to the dc booth at san diego
or emerald city or new york comic con
you couldn't buy anything that was right
there were vendors elsewhere on the
floor and that was their things that
we're going to
drive up interest and you go and buy
that [ __ ] from them who have already
bought it from us
but if they now open their own [ __ ]
fandom in you know some
i don't know they're selling shirts bet
she's selling shirts i'll buy one
yup um so plushies say dc fandom
maybe even a hat oh put your fan dome on
i'm in yeah this is a marketable event
for them they get this is they're you're
gonna see you're seeing the future right
now
someone at dc and warner brothers was
like hey i think we just figured out a
way to make some money
off this not only that but it seems to
have
smoked and mirrors the way the fact that
we laid off a third of our staff a week
ago no mention of that under the fandom
not so much interesting bob harris long
time editor-in-chief
for the last 10 years over dc prior to
that he'd been at marvel for a long
spell
uh he was one of the people that was let
go and the recent
you know dc implosion if you will um but
they were the folks that were let go due
to california law and that's where dc is
now based
they you got to give somebody what three
week notice or three month notice or
something that [ __ ]
so a lot of people found out they were
getting let go of and then we're gonna
be sitting around working
for another few months or something uh
bob harris i just read an article i
think i'm bleeding cool
uh he he was like [ __ ] it and he left
i mean i'm sure there's the version of
we either you can work for another three
months or we pay you out
for a month and a half probably got a
nice little golden parachute and [ __ ]
off
um yeah no mention of that at the fandom
not so much and like
we talked before about how ray fisher
was there for the zack snyder reveal
yes um it seems as if and we had also
talked in the past about ray fisher's
sort of very public outing of uh what he
termed you know
shenanigans on the set of joss whedon's
reshoots for justice league
now warner media has opened an
investigation based on those tweets hold
on are we out of the fandom officially
now we are officially out of the
we're outside the glass of the fandom
now ladies and gentlemen this is where
you get the real story
this is where you get the dirt
apparently yes this happened a few days
before
fandom it did i'm putting on my glasses
to reach mark's going old man on us
yeah um he's coming through now khan
right
genius um love it uh ray fisher
has been talking about or not really
talking about
um tweeting or implying uh or
inferring no inferring is when you get
something from somebody what would you
say
i would say alleging dropping dime
in his phrase i mean he he on july 1st
he was tweeting about josh whedon's
gross and abusive conduct on set
um john sweden's onset treatment of the
cast and crew of justice league was
gross abusive unprofessional and
completely unacceptable
he was enabled in many ways by jeff
johns and john berg
accountability over entertainment was
his july 1st tweet and we covered it
here on the show
indeed and i talked about some stuff i'd
heard while i was on
a star wars set in england from people
who worked on both versions of
justice league um and then some news
sites were like kevin smith says it's
true even though i was like look this is
just what i heard from some other people
and ray fisher like retweeted me and
said something nice about me and stuff
um
so that was you know back in july yes
then he tweeted again a second time
if i remember correctly right um
something about his job was threatened
right there was repercussions that were
that were you know
offered that if he continued to speak up
or whatever if he you know told on
people
there would be you know implications
indications
threats that his career would take a hit
because of it
then the last thing we heard which was
just this week before fandom began
is this is uh fisher tweeted after five
weeks of interviews with various cast
and crew
warner media has officially launched an
independent third party investigation
to get to the heart of the toxic and
abusive work environment created during
justice league reshoots
this is a massive step forward i believe
this investigation will show that jeff
johns joss whedon john berg and others
grossly abused their power during the
uncertainty of att's merger with time
warner
now and it has been confirmed that this
investigation is happening so
it's for real it's for reals what do you
make of uh
that i mean it it's it seems as if we
are in a
time where corporations are increasingly
aware
of this sort of thing um you know
prime the pump was primed by the sort of
metoo movement and how
the idea that oh [ __ ] turns out hr has
not been doing as good a job as it
should be and people absolutely abuse
their power
in ways that that create an unsafe work
environment
and so ray fisher apparently you know
what more can you do to my career
decided well [ __ ] it let's go public and
the going public of it has
prompted people at the very least at
warner media again in the middle of a
very
public moment where we're launching hbo
max and we're doing the dc fandom and
all eyes are on us we need to now
suddenly be upfront about
you know the way we allow people to
conduct business on our behalf
smart then it's very smart you know
from a corporate perspective it's smart
because you got to cover your ass you
know because at the end of the day
that's what they're looking to do
you know corporations are never never in
it to do the right thing
they're in it to do things that minimize
their exposure
yeah and the second version of this
movie was you know as we've seen based
on
stories you know going as far back as
two years ago
they rushed out justice league so they
can get their bonuses before the at
t merger there was some conjecture about
or
confirmed stories about it and uh you
know
nobody in this business was shocked
that people in this business wanted put
their best interests or their own
interests over the best interests of the
movie going public they don't
they're not in this to be nice and stuff
like that they're in it to make money
and stuff but now it seems like
corporate world waking up to the fact
that like fandom has a very loud voice
yeah i mean so much so that there is a
zack snyder's justice league
totally like the the fandom sword cuts
both ways yeah he can give you
awesomeness it can it can render unto
you what is caesar's
but at the same token they can make it
so that hey if we don't feel like this
is legit
we don't feel like this is on the up and
up but we think that you have been
sort of disrespecting at the least and
and
wounding at the worst the people who
make your content
then perhaps we don't show up in mass
for it anymore um good for him and he's
good it sounds like he's getting some
justice
like at the very least look it's a third
party investigation and
you know who knows what they find if
they find some stuff if they don't find
some stuff
at least somebody heard the man yeah
taking him seriously because it
you could see he was hurting over it
this ain't just a matter of
you know this is an injustice which
clearly it is
it was there was some personal hurt
there there was some personal hurt and
you know potentially
allegedly a threat to a person's
longevity and livelihood
which feels you know above and beyond
beyond the pale
of a thing that you would do to a person
who may or may not have a legitimate
grievance
about the people who pay him money and
that's fair and that's that's fine and
then
you know in a moment where people are
beginning to own their voice and
beginning to speak up and beginning to
to say what's on their mind good bad or
indifferent
to not listen would be the biggest
injustice
so true um and also i got to imagine
all this snyder cut
like helps you know what i'm saying like
if there was no snyder cut they could
easily be like well justice league
i was in the past right there they know
that they're dealing with zach they see
how
big the snyder cut has been for them
it's a [ __ ] marketing hook for them
on hbo max
creates a lot of enthusiasm and whatnot
excitement and
cyborg is apparently the fulcrum upon
which much of the snyder cut hangs
yeah because a lot of that character got
cut out and so and
and so you can see based on that trailer
totally there's a bunch of [ __ ] in there
about
[ __ ] you know ray fisher and
if this is going to be the narrative of
the movie going forward and this is a
guy who's saying that i was [ __ ] over
by the studio
you got to get at the bottom of it and
find a way to make restitution whether
that's public apology whether it's money
whether it's a
you know [ __ ] overall deal whatever
it is you got to make this go away
it doesn't sound like he wants anything
but you know truth to come out
a little bit of justice a little bit
honesty accountability yeah
you know and to let people see the work
that he did i mean i that too
i remember you know sitting down and
watching justice league and i was
impressed by him i was like he's doing a
lot with his character that doesn't have
a lot of time
i liked his delivery like when i first
heard his voice the low key quiet
delivery and stuff yeah but yeah
clearly and his scenes in that movie
with his dad particularly are like
really good
yeah and the stuff with flash was also
super fun yeah um so to see more of him
and to hopefully get to see more of him
in the future
if that's what comes out of this then
all the better and he was kind of the
way in
for the audience too he was the human
character who was
undergoing something huge and then
joining the justice league so yeah
we saw a completely different movie
based on the trailer they showed us
today
so the one we were watching when youtube
threw us off when warner music decided
that you were
new copyright um all right what else we
got
we got um you know meanwhile over at
marvel
um who what what are they up to
i mean [ __ ] if i'm those if i'm these
cats right now i'm like uh we're doing a
fandom
yeah under the shield it's the fan
shield
under the shield there you go um they
it's it's less marvel and it's more sony
sony is beginning to uh
make some moves beginning to make some
moves to heat up their
ultimately spider-man universe well they
uh things worked out quite
well with uh disney and kevin feige so
apparently they're like all right full
speed ahead we're going to have support
from the disney side with our
spider-verse
you know and to a certain degree even if
they don't this all of their marvel work
is spinning out of spider-man
and so olivia wilde has signed on to
direct a new marvel movie for sony
the the popular rumor which seems like
all the reporting is
is spider woman yeah jessica drew
spider woman uh that would that would be
fun that makes sense but look
i'll watch anything she directs because
i love book smart yeah
i mean give her a movie give her more
movies part of me was hoping that it was
a spider gwen movie
ah yeah it could be look they haven't
confirmed they haven't confirmed it but
you know that that idea of like the bird
doing high school
taking gwen stacy in high school uh
just i like your version better i like
that more than
spider woman yeah i mean i also don't
have a particular
deep connection to jessica drew um cool
outfit
yeah i mean super cool but you know
doesn't do for me what gwen stacy and
spider-gwen yeah we all connected pretty
hardcore with gwen stacy thank you
thanks to the characters up and also
into the spider-verse however
in the right hands spider woman jessica
drew becomes the character that you
didn't know you loved as much as you do
for sure and in her hands very capable
of that that move that book smart movie
is wonderful yeah so she is directing
and co-writing
um again there is no idea when this is
coming out she just signed the deal now
um but speaking of sony and marvel and
spider-man universe
there might be a crave in the hunter
movie for reals
so now would this be
there's been speculation that craven is
the bad guy
in spider-man homesick or whatever
that was speculated that last week that
it's spider-man homesick
um the next spider-man movie that's so
that's not
been confirmed it hasn't been confirmed
but it also wouldn't be
surprising if you introduce him in
spider-man 3
and then give him his own face and spin
him out of that um
or if you do a movie with him first and
then fold him in
as the nemesis so that you've done all
of the work so that now we understand
you don't have to give the the origin
story freight for spider-man 3 if you
give him his own movie yeah so don't
really have much origin story freight to
just be like this guy came to town to
kill spider-man
who is he do it his name's craven the
hunter great we're moving yeah what's he
do he hunts
yeah what's his origin gives a [ __ ]
moving forward he's russian
i guess um wow any word
um jc chandor oh is in line to direct
he directed triple frontier amongst many
movies he did indeed
um so yeah like it's it seems as if sony
is
and who knows if all these movies are
gonna get made who knows if they if if
this much
announce them all let god sort them out
pretty much like if this much spider-man
ancillary content is what the universe
is actually asking for because we have
venom two coming
we have morbus morbius coming both of
which are sort of on the shelves they
were supposed to be the tail end of this
year now spilling it to 2021.
hey sure okay if they're good i'm down
for them
but it's a lot of it's a lot of
spider-man adjacent
it's a lot of spider-man without
spider-man yes yes which
always iffy but you know what venom
worked venom venom worked for a lot of
people
despite itself it did what it needed to
was to make a [ __ ] ton of money at the
box office god yes
and so it seems as if sony took the hint
that yeah no no people want more
they put up there they were like let's
double down on the spider stuff
we're diving head first straight up the
ass into the spider verse
um so yeah that's that's that's some
spider-verse [ __ ] that's happening
and uh and the final story is uh
it's a cautionary tale i feel okay um
for your average filmmaker who's out
kind of doing press for a movie that has
no release date or has a release date
but the new mutants director
josh boone lovely guy i've had him on
the podcast
apparently like he should maybe stop
doing interviews why what do you say
because he said uh i do think people
should be going to the movies
if they can go to a house party with 700
people without mass on they can put on a
mask and go to a movie and maybe get
their rocks off in a more productive way
interesting take it's a way to come at
it
i suppose but using the oh right uh the
governor
and the mayor are shutting down houses
that are throwing these crazy parties
um maybe not using that as a paragon of
behavior to model after
and also it's just like look i'm 50
years old so i don't know how kids
operate these days but i got a 21 year
old daughter at home so maybe i got a
little
inclination um
i don't think the kids that go to house
parties
go to movies and i don't think they're
going to see a substitute for like
it's like hey let's go watch that movie
that's been delayed for a couple [ __ ]
thousand years
yeah that's not i don't know if that's
quite the cell of the movie i would take
but tough to sell
the movie period essentially he's got to
convince people to
fight the virus to go out there into the
world man right
like the what are the odds does not feel
like it's a really strong marketing push
still i'm going to see it i won't
you're not going to see it i mean not in
the theaters but i will eventually see
it
but i am not going out at the tail end
of august to go and check out
i agree i probably won't be going out to
see it in the theater
um but i will see it when it's ready man
so i you know
i i i get your pain josh boone i
understand your dilemma
this poor kid come on you make the fault
in our stars movie makes
100 million plus huge [ __ ] hit
and then you're like right on i'm gonna
follow it up [ __ ] the new mutants man
and then it yes we're gonna shoot this
thing in like six months
we're gonna get it out like six months
later man it's me 2017 is my year and
then you cut
to uh spongebob squarepants going 10
years later it's been a [ __ ] long
time so i who who could blame him for
being like oh man
yeah get this out of my life is he
working on the stand right now
um i'm not sure it wasn't i think he was
working on the stand
for cbs for the app i mean i don't know
how i mean i don't know if they're shut
down but
right last i heard he was working on
that i mean i i hope that comes together
for him faster than the mutants did
i mean [ __ ] anything would at this point
that movie that poor movie's cursed
uh but you know just it's been delayed
sometimes movies that get delayed under
curse though
turn out to be okay yeah can't think of
any examples off the top of my head but
i'm looking forward to seeing it mad max
fury road there you go
that movie was supposed to come out a
bunch of different times it was
shut down by [ __ ] desert storms and
terrorism and all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
and then literally like there was oh
there's a coup in this country we've got
to leave and then when it comes out it
turns out to be
one of the great movies of the last 10
years there you go man there's some hope
for this new me here's some picture it
could be a modern day fury road
delay does not necessarily imply quality
delay could just mean
delight indeed maybe he's just a delay
fish
that be that the end of the news that's
the end of the news man mark got the
news for you man but before we do
anything else
uh you did not talk about something i
know you wanted to talk about
what was that um lovecraft country love
you watched it i did and i haven't seen
it yet i'm gonna wait till a few
episodes
gather up because i went to watch
[ __ ] perry mason
[Laughter]
andrew loves perry mason but i talked
about it off the air the you know i
[ __ ] went to watch perry mason and
it was
and now andrew loves it ralph garmin
loves it
my wife loved it but i was just like oh
hold on
man and then when it was done first
episode i'm like all right let's go to
the next one i'm sure
[ __ ] will get going and she's like
there's no next one i'm like oh it's a
weekly [ __ ]
so i i'm letting like that whole season
build up so i could
it's done the pair mason's over i will
be watching all of perry mason so i want
to let a few episodes
gather up i will say that the lovecraft
country pilot begins with
um your main hero a fellow named atticus
um who is in the korean war and it's
korean war footage black and white
he's like running through trenches like
stabbing [ __ ] and then suddenly
uh flying saucers show up the [ __ ] all
right say no more
flying like [ __ ] cthulhu makes an
appearance deja thorus
from [ __ ] john quarter of mars
episode one the first
five minutes of episode one oh my god
today just got exciting it's everything
it's all of the [ __ ] pulp heroes does
it work
it works well and you know [ __ ]
jackie robinson cuts cthulhu in half
with a baseball bat
in the first five minutes it's a dream
sequence your hero's having this crazy
dream sequel
who wrote this um misha green who was
the showrunner for um
for underground was on wgn harry tubman
story
um and it's a it's a j.j abrams slash um
jordan peele jr and uh and
much like watchmen they got all the
money to make it and so that is just
literally setting the mind space of your
main hero
a felony manicus who is a korean war
veteran
um who had been living in kentucky who
gets called back home to chicago because
his father's gone missing
and so you're you're sort of living with
him and the kind of black
experience in the 50s and 60s dealing
with both the jim crow
south and the experience of racism in
the north
um and it spends a decent amount of time
just kind of you know the first 20
minutes of the pilot after crazy
insane fantasia of kind of rooting you
in the world of these characters like
courtney b vance plays
his uncle um anjanu ellis plays his aunt
and and journey smaller and journey
smallett plays
black canary black canary who she plays
it's a little mysterious for me what her
relationship is to all of these people
beyond
she's from this block they were friends
as kids she's now desperate for a job
courtney b vance is a publisher of
what's called a safe traveler's guide
which in if you've seen the movie green
book i'm sorry but
it is what the green books were which
were if you were a person of color
traveling through the country here's
where you could eat safely here's where
you could sleep safely hear the towns is
that what green book's about
um that's part of it like it's it's the
the reason why
in that movie mahershala needed viggo
mortensen was i am a black musician
traveling doing a circuit in the south
and i need protection because if i go to
these places
it's not legit but and it's a real thing
that existed it's a piece of history
and so courtney once again hbo hbo
dishing out some black history for a
bunch of white people that were like
that's a thing i guess it's like the
high school i never had
once a week i learned some [ __ ] and uh
and so they decide to go in and find out
what happened to his uncle and then it
gets to be another road trip and there's
these three people in a car
and the most harrowing sequence i've
seen on film this year so far
is the slowest car chase i've ever seen
it is these characters who get pulled
over by a cop
and the cop is like uh okay well listen
i'm not gonna pull you over i could do
awful [ __ ] to you but
it turns out uh i'm not going to do it
now
but you got to get out of my town before
sundown because after sundown
if you as a negro traveler get caught
then
then your ass is mine and the state line
is like eight miles away
but the speed limit is 25 miles an hour
holy [ __ ]
are you serious cop is riding their tail
hoping they don't make the state line
and they can't speed and so it's a race
for the sun that's going down
and they're trying their best to get
over [ __ ] train tracks and it's the
tensest most horrific thing you've seen
episode one episode one you just [ __ ]
sold the ticket
i'm not waiting anymore man i was gonna
wait for a bunch of episodes how many
episodes they do so far uh the first one
i mean this sunday will be
episode two all right so i'll watch it
yeah wednesday saturday yeah
so i can either i watch it i might watch
it it means that sounds [ __ ]
dope i might go home wake up my wife and
be like get up
really i don't want to [ __ ] i'm like
we're not [ __ ] we're watching the
show love
craft countries that sounds dope that's
a good sequence it's a great sequence
and then you know
i'm not going to tell you where it goes
but also [ __ ] sug-off creatures
straight out of lovecraft show up crazy
demon dogs with a thousand eyes that
turn out to be vampires
100 show up by the end of this pilot
when they say love craft country is that
the name like do they reference
lovecraft in it
um they reference lovecraft as an author
who existed in that time and they
reference you know the arkham
idea of you know there's this
penitentiary and there's this school and
there's the you know
like when we think of arkham we're like
batman but like they stole it they stole
it
um and it's a really interesting way of
of
repurposing h.p lovecraft work because
that dude was racist yeah it was pretty
racist crazy racist
and so in recent years i didn't know
that when i was growing up like when you
watch reanimator nobody's ever like
guy that created this racist as [ __ ]
virulent racist i mean
and it's a thing that that black nerds
have to deal with being fans of this
stuff like
john carter so he's a confederate
soldier
like and he's a dude who falls asleep in
a cave john carter of mars
and then edgar rice pearl's created that
character like he was a confederate
soldier
yeah did they do that in the disney
movie they do
they hand wave it a bit but like that
dude fought for the south
and then falls asleep in a cave and
everything you ever wanted to have
happened happens
like i want to go on an adventure with
princesses and swords and lasers
he falls asleep and wakes up on mars
that's the story
that's the [ __ ] story the laziest
dimensional travel ever wow
um but robert e howard he created wait
wait but when you were a kid did you
know
about the lovecraft i didn't um it was
later in life that you heard and then
you were like well now i got to figure
out what i feel like about it but and
like conan the barbarian
was seminal for me like i spent an
entire summer reading
who is that robert robert e howard also
crazy racist
is he really yeah and so and i love
those books
like the conan books the conan books
love and the death
yeah so let me ask you i mean side note
so you know how star trek you like glove
star trek
if somebody came to you and they're like
we'd like you to do conan 100
yes that's your dream uh i'm not gonna
say it's a dream
but it would be a [ __ ] delight to get
to play in that
arena you hear that universe i'm just
saying
like ryan ryan condell is a writer
director
um television show runner i had heard
through the wind
that he had he was hired to develop
conan as a tv show for amazon
no and i legit [ __ ] emailed him out
of the blue and i was like dude
i know that you know you're a thousand
miles away from being able to get this
done
and i'm sure that once you get it done
there's a list of people you want to
work on this
let me tell you this is my [ __ ]
mother's milk like these were the first
books that i fell in love with his books
like i wrote a [ __ ] ton of comics and
but again conan was the first comic i
ever got
really my dad brought home savage sort
of conan where do you stand on the
movies
um i love the schwarzenegger the first
one conan barbarian is pretty great is
it close
to the material or no not quite because
oliver stone wrote it right oliver stone
wrote it
um and and yeah what's millions
directing millions
emily has turned it into this weird
[ __ ] like men's rights version of
conan the barbarian it's a very [ __ ]
metal and
yeah it's it's it's its own thing i
still love it to death but it's not
the it's not the text of the books
destroyer is okay you get
you know whatever destroyer falls apart
when you see the destroyer yeah like oh
that's it
yeah oh tinfoil and a horn it's a guild
navigator like but the junior version of
it
okay and i i wasn't that big a fan of
the jason mamoa version of conan
i didn't see that yeah it's okay is it
closer to the books or no not really
it's it's closer too as far as you're
concerned for your money nobody's really
done
the conan that you know yet no and i
think part of it is finding that
actor who can play conan and
schwarzenegger is probably closest to it
well he has to be [ __ ] huge he's got
to have he's got to stand out he's got
to look as if he doesn't belong anywhere
and schwarzenegger had that
mass and that feeling and that scale
that mamoa while ripped and cut and kind
of funny is not that dude
about idris elba he's still too frail
like really yeah like john's what about
the rock the rock
is that guy like it's you get the once
in a generation
giant [ __ ] bodybuilder who can pull
that off
and the rock has the charisma to make
that work
but yes the the reckoning with the the
stuff you loved as a kid that you've
discovered the people who wrote that
stuff
right or totally would would hate the
fact that not only are you reading it
but in misha green's case that she's
writing the adaptation
of stuff inspired by him kind of
heartbreaking yet at the same time
it's kind of delicious victorious yeah
yeah um and so
this is a series that is taking a lot of
the the
the underground the underpinnings of
what makes lovecraft work
monsters and elder gods and demons and
and interdimensional
[ __ ] conquest and all of that stuff
but also
turning it into a world in which racism
is the monster like by the time you get
to the last scene where the [ __ ]
thousand-eyed demon slugs come out of
the ground you breathe a sigh of relief
because
[ __ ] at least it's not racism
[Laughter]
that was awful here's a monster that i
can deal with that i can kill you could
kill the monster
i can kill the monster and you know and
i think
i'm not spoiling anything because i
don't know anything but judging by the
trailer for the episodes to come
you get to the legit mansion in the
northeast of america where there's crazy
[ __ ] people summoning gods from
beneath and
mind control and all of that [ __ ] seems
to be happening
in short order i'm like [ __ ] what hbo
is on fire right
and it's like you they had to have put
these things into like between this and
watchmen
long time ago i made this not even like
finger on the pulse
moments kind of they it had to be years
ago yeah three four five years ago they
saw these these
pictures i remember that i remember the
um
after get out that was when i like jj
said something like like i remember
talking about pitching he's like i'm
going in to pitch something with
with jordan like next week and i guess
that was
it yeah crazy and he said it was like
like you know all horror movies but done
through like a different perspective
which kind of sounds like that's what it
is it's what it is
and and there's also like it's beautiful
there's a lot of these shots
that feel ripped from like gordon park's
photography from life magazine
of ice cream counters in the south
that's like you know
whites only and you know these these
tableaus of american life that also
betray
the iniquities of american life at the
same time that's like gorgeous and
pastel and the colors are vibrant but
it's telling this story
that that seems to be far uglier than
the pictures that are telling it
um well put this is a writer right there
it's incredibly well done and incredibly
well crafted and it's about something
underneath
and also it delivers on what you want it
to deliver on like it's fun and
like because it's scary and monsters and
[ __ ] but it also has like
yeah like good sci-fi it entertains you
up top with like
monsters and then underneath you're like
monsters
we're the monsters yeah yeah i mean
that's kind of the idea isn't it
um right on there's a [ __ ] hearty
suggestion right there i'm totally
watching now i'm gonna wait for a few
episodes i'll just
down one tonight and then down the new
one tomorrow yeah
i i was i was very impressed by it so if
you have not seen lovecraft country
i highly recommend it um journey smallit
is a [ __ ]
hero like she's amazing she
uh i liked her in uh in the harley quinn
movies birds of prey
but uh she got a lot of attention for
this when i think she was the cover
hollywood reporter and stuff like that
there's there's this amazing like
it in the animals saw a shot of her
running she looked like tom cruise
yeah it's the like of all of you holo
runs that you see
it's like in every hour movie there's
the woman who screams and the woman who
runs
and some runs are good and some aren't
and some screams are good and some
aren't but like she's a [ __ ] track
star
just like fists are pumping and oh
that's awesome
i'm in man uh there it is [ __ ]
lovecraft country it's
on hbo right now watch it hbo killing it
man all that dc fandom stuff [ __ ]
going to wind up under
on some point hbo max eventually
uh what a great time to be alive and
consuming [ __ ] entertainment that
works the way it does now
[ __ ] how awesome so much
entertainment so much content
indeed we'll get to it all one day and
we all we did was see a little bit of
the future for most of the
day today yeah man but it sounds like
with the present we got something to
watch
i'm gonna [ __ ] go watch that i mean
he's gotta come in and go good man like
i was gonna wait for like i'll wait till
they get five episodes up but
now i'll [ __ ] now i'll do that like
i've been doing um
i may destroy you oh i [ __ ] love that
show
it's coming to an end and i'm kind going
to be sad when it's done
but um maybe they'll just give me a new
thing to watch
and the boys is about to start the boys
are back can't [ __ ] wait man
ah what a great time to be alive yes
2020 sucks but at the same time
it's also good because there are things
coming right you can't get to 2021
without 2020. so all we have to do is
survive this [ __ ]
survive and then give us a cool batman
movie
with riddler [ __ ] taping up his head
[ __ ] that looks
metal if if the boys season two doesn't
in some fashion use the boys are back in
town
as a theme song disappointment missed
opportunity i will feel
somewhat slighted i like to think that
show's so like [ __ ] outside the box
that they're like come on
rookie we're not gonna do that that's a
little too obvious and [ __ ] you saw that
sequence of like the boat going through
the giant whale
so i can't [ __ ] wait so well man
there it is folks did you have a good
time on saturday night
we delayed mark wisely delayed uh he
said the other day he was like
let's maybe we should wait till saturday
to do the show because
fandom will happen and we'll have some
[ __ ] to talk about and i was like oh
that makes sense
and thank god we did yeah this is all we
talked about
like friday like well uh sony's making a
couple spider-man movies
and then the world tears in half because
of this [ __ ] times in half
then we gotta wait another week to talk
about it big winner of the weekend has
got to be
uh warner brothers dc man yeah like this
is [ __ ] huge they got their own d23
going now
everybody excited [ __ ] they own
twitter all day long they own
social media and one of the coolest
things that i saw like i didn't watch it
wall-to-wall
um because again i had to wash my ass at
some point but
there was a and and the smartest thing
they did was make every panel short
yeah everything was like 20 25 minutes
long that is smart
it's very smart but they had this this
happened especially because everyone's
like shut up
play the trailer yeah give it a come on
[ __ ] move out of the way
fine wig um but they have this little
art critique
like they had apparently looked at a
bunch of different artists and jim lee
was giving this aspiring artist a
critique
um and he you know he and jim said like
i looked at a bunch of people but i
thought your art was the closest to
being
kind of ready but still needed some
advice to get to the next step and he
gave him three pieces to critique and
like
jim put it up on his [ __ ] artboard
and was like all right i would do this
here and this here and this is really
strong and your handwork is good you're
kind of like
literally just watching because we
rarely get to see that yeah
it's a professional giving notes to
somebody who's clearly got talent
but could be great if but for a little
bit of help and
and it was super instructive and like
just watching that level
of of care and attentiveness between
artists
about a thing they both love you know
one dude who's 100 down to learn some
[ __ ] and one guy was happy to share
knowledge
and it was just like yeah like that's
that's a fandom that's a guy who loves
this stuff
talking to another guy who loves this
stuff about how to make it better
and he's and he's a great dude too and
he's a really great such
i mean aside from the talent and all
that [ __ ] just a real good human being
yeah so it was it was a nice thing to
see in the midst of
this kind of wall-to-wall parade
marketing
of marketing a lot of like look we're
trying to sell you [ __ ] nice to see a
human moment in there yeah
where some guy's like look i'm gonna try
to give you a little piece of advice
maybe that helps you to the next level
it's nice yeah so that was cool so i
appreciate that other fandom
and i think he gave him a fanned up if
you will oh
nice dc call me i've got a lot of those
but it does it does feel as if it's it's
it is now the
the model for which people will begin to
pattern their own version virtual
versions of conventions after
because it it was incredibly successful
um from a functionality point of view
from a content point of view
and and from a hey if i got to give up a
saturday for for something
this was a pretty cool way to give it up
i give up every saturday if they give me
a new batman trailer
every day of my life till i die here for
you every saturday don't even have to
show me the movie just show me the
trailer
we'll [ __ ] obsess over it next week a
new one
great time to be alive indeed uh thank
you
for hanging out with us today ladies and
gentlemen also aquaman two
bring an arm back i saw yes and
apparently a
a more serious version yeah what does
that mean they're like serious more
socially relevant like
yeah more you know fighting covert we're
gonna get deep into the lives of the
sharks that we ride upon
yes let's see if we're all breathing
water or
you know underwater why are we riding
them why aren't they right here
how do we get to primacy in the
underworld we're we're in the minority
yet we're in control here
this feels ripe for revolution yeah
maybe that's how they do it what do you
think it means though relevant like
not like we got to clean up the oceans
like all right
but you know you know i don't know
global warming aquaman 2 aquaman vs
trump they're like there's how it's
relevant
here we go places it right now right
today
uh there it is folks you have a good
time i hope you did
uh boy oh boy we wouldn't have had the
time we had
without the man on the other side of the
glass put it on the glass
for the great mark barnard ladies and
gentlemen look at him there
uh thank you for hanging out thanks
andrew
for getting them graphics and them
trailers up there and a spinny little
thing
and just thanks jc for giving us a home
and uh you saw him spring into action
the moment putting out fires
yeah oh my god when youtube threw us off
he was like damn you
and he made it put us right back up and
stuff so uh
thanks to our one lone audience member
deacon was hanging out there in the back
and stuff
remember uh 3 40 x what was the other
one 40 xn
screen x screen x i always forget that
one um
there'll be a time when we all get to
sit in those [ __ ] rocket chairs again
while they shoot [ __ ] in our face and
make pretend that we're in the [ __ ]
movie
as the chair rolls around and stuff one
day
we'll be back there i'm sure they're
open what about new york and places like
that
is that right so 40x theaters everywhere
else except
california and new york deacon said are
opening
now so that's awesome outstanding um we
picked the wrong state to live in
we were a real head of the game here in
california i can't believe we got
through all this show we didn't even
talk about tenant but you know what
we'll hold it until next week
indeed because people have seen tenants
people are starting to see it not us
yeah [ __ ] never us
other people are but in that that was
weird like [ __ ]
like he's not under the fandom you know
what i'm saying i mean
they probably could have made an
exception i mean like everyone leaves
royalty under the fandom right with dark
knight i mean
he should get like the [ __ ] disney
founders pass that they can always go
into the fandom
if they want give them a half hour or
say some batman [ __ ] people go crazy
crazy and at the end of it be like 10 at
peace out and then leave and stuff
backwards and forwards i'll see you at
the thief
there it is folks uh for fat man beyond
uh i'm kevin smith
i am mark bernard tune in next week same
fat time although it might be on friday
same fat channel hopefully still on
youtube yes uh don't forget
order doordash right now when i get home
i'm ordering up some doordash going to
watch some lovecraft
code fat man to become a fatter man
that's right and get a little money off
at the same time
indeed same fat time same fat channel
ladies and gentlemen don't forget
hollywood babylon it's happening at the
drive-in
on monday night tickets at csmod.com
10th anniversary show
same fat time same fat i'm thinking of
doing is there everything else we need
to sell
any more housekeeping movies pop up
ladies and gentlemen moving
to red bag new jersey and this week i
think or next week we'll tell you where
it is expressly but
uh you can still get it on la post mates
uh go to movies pop-up or you can order
anywhere in the united states goldbelly
will bring it to you at moviespopup.com
same fat time you got anything to plug
same
fat channel don't forget to floss back
spodcast.com or youtube.com kevin smith
may the force be with you
you